hi how are you good thanks come I have
been standing for eight hours and I'm in
a terrible mood
it looks like you erased the entire
contents of your phone but sure I don't
take responsibility I'm saying I need to
go in the back to check for size I'm
really going in the back to check my
Instagram
oh I'm pretending like I didn't just see
porn pop up on your computer you're
super cute I'm gonna act so professional
to cover up how nervous I am hello this
blouse looks terrible on you but I'm a
hundred dollars away from my sales go
yes girl it's yes no we're out of stock
for the 100th time
oh no price tag must be free I've
already heard that joke six times today
and it's not even my lunch break yet
where can you buy that obscure adapter I
don't know I'll google it no but you're
misinterpreting good customer services
flirting yeah I'm watching you still
that accessory but go ahead cuz I'm not
allowed to confront you directly no you
can't return that item without a receipt
but let me go get my manager so we can
tell the exact same thing we're
understaffed today so I'm just gonna
make an excuse to head into the back oh
you're great with technology then why
are you here I haven't had a full
weekend off in four months